Well, congratulations on being Teacher of the Year.
Thank you so much.
And I understand you teach science to very young kids.
Yeah, my class is called STEAM Lab,...
...science, technology, engineering, arts and math.
I can talk to them about how all those different subjects integrate together...
...and the skills that they use transfer across.
At that young age, do you get all the kids pretty engaged?
The boys and the girls?
Oh yeah, definitely.
I do projects in the arts and creative problem-solving,...
...really working on developing those soft skills,...
...you know, collaboration, creativity, critical thinking skills.
Yeah, it's interesting you put art in there as well.
Yeah, and I use it a lot to just talk to students about how it's that imagination,...
...that creativity, the innovation side of their brain...
...that they're always using no matter what else they're doing...
...and those people who are going to be the most successful in the future...
...are going to be people that have that lens on,...
"Okay, how can I make this work better?"
"How can I solve the problem?"
Well, it's inspiring to hear what you're doing.
Thanks so much for spending time with me.
Thank you so much, I really appreciate it.